c'est d'aller bonjour merci d'être en
direct avec nous sur rt france a la
nette impression que marathon s'éternise
actuellement aux etats-unis 1
on ne connaît toujours pas de vainqueur
on a un avantage très net pour joe biden
qui est en tête pour l'instant quelle
est votre lecture justement deux de ces
élections
tout d'abord ces élections ont montré la
solidité de la base de 30 parce que
après son échec par rapport à la copie
par rapport à une économie qui
finalement depuis le début de l'année ne
marche pas très très bien
on s'attendait à un raz-de-marée
démocrate
ce raz-de-marée n'a pas eu lieu il n'a
pas eu lieu
ni au niveau de la présidentielle ni au
niveau du congrès et non plus au niveau
des gouverneurs des élections des
gouverneurs donc finalement 30 résiste
mais il y a un avantage net
maintenant pour les démocrates en tout
cas pour le démocrate joe brydon ce
n'est pas encore gagné mais il est bien
parti pour est là ce n'est pas encore
gagnée puisqu'il reste encore quatre
états qui reste incertain on sait que le
dépouillement des votes continue
notamment les votes par correspondance
mais ces votes par correspondance
pourrait justement pencher plus en
faveur du démocrate joe biden pourquoi
justement on estime d'ailleurs selon
toutes les études les démocrates
sus à l'image de leur chef de file
maintenant joe biden avait des
réticences par rapport à halak au vide
c'est un comportement un peu qui
correspond à la vie à l'opinion des
démocrates rapport à cette crise
sanitaire pour éviter de longues files
d'attentes pour éviter des encombrements
devant les urnes
beaucoup de démocrates avaient préféré
envoyer leur bulletin par courrier et et
est donc en estime que
à plus de démocrates qui envoient des
bulletins par les urnes que de
républicains qui eux mêmes pour les
républicains
ils ont été mobilisés par 30 lui-même
dont des métiers d'ondés en tout cas des
spots télévisés et donc on estime que
les républicains se sont déplacés
massivement le mardi on a comptabilisé
les comptes pour mardi il reste
maintenant on est en train de dépouiller
les votes par correspondance
pour l'instant ce sont des résultats
voilà qui ne plaisent pas justement à
donald trump donald trump
qui a d'ailleurs plusieurs fois crié à
la fraude électorale il veut engager une
bataille judiciaire
il avait déjà dit d'ailleurs avant même
le dépouillement des bulletins de vote
est-ce que voilà c'est le risque après
voilà ce cafouillage on va dire pour
l'instant dans le décompte des voix on
se retrouve face à une bataille devant
les tribunaux autres joe biden et donald
trump
si on n'a pas des résultats d'ici demain
peut-être ou dc certainement demain si
on n'a pas des résultats nets en faveur
de doutes eurent brydon on est parti
pour des procédures extrêmement longue
extrêmement compliqué parce que 30 ne va
pas accepter sa défaite facilement et
cette démarche là c'est procédure là
était déjà prévu depuis des mois la
plupart des spécialistes avaient prévu
des procédures extrêmement compliqué et
une détermination sans faille de la part
des républicains et de la part de 30
pour aller jusqu'au bout de la procédure
judiciaire
donc si on n'a pas de résultat net d si
quelques heures c'est que on va passer
par une procédure attendu tout à fait
normal quelque part dans le système
américain en ouganda on avait vu déjà en
2000 quand il s'agissait de l'élection
de george bush
donc finalement 32 va pas se laisser
comme ça écarté de la maison blanche
facilement
pour revenir un petit peu à ce scrutin
il a vraiment passionné les américains
une amérique on le dit fracture est
divisé en deux on parle d'un taux record
près de 67 % de participation à ces
élections et aujourd'hui je le disais
c'est un petit peu la pagaille dans ce
décompte
on n'a pas toujours voilà l'impression
que c'est clair des comptes et qu'il
faut justement voir de très près un
candidat un état qui peut tout faire
basculer est ce que vous pensez
qu'aujourd'hui le système électoral
américain est en danger après justement
ce que l'on voit ces derniers jours le
sist pour les américains il s'attache
beaucoup à leurs traditions politiques à
leur constitution qui a été rédigée en
je ne pense pas qu'on est parti même si
jobs avait promis de travailler sur une
relecture une refondation du système
électoral je pense tout d'abord il sera
comme on dit en anglais
les docks pour un certain moment
c'est-à-dire un canard boiteux
1 parce que si le sénat reste dans les
mains des républicains si les démocrates
perdent légèrement le terrain à la
chambre il ne va pas pouvoir changer le
système politique le système politique a
montré comme un des failles mais en même
temps il a montré des points forts c'est
un système qui marche depuis des
décennies c'est un des siècles je pense
que ce serait très très compliqué
d'engager une procédure de changement
delà des procédures en tout cas du code
électoral
hélas ce système là ce code électoral a
montré des faiblesses l'a montré des
limites mais certainement l'amérique
dans quelques semaines c 'est pas dans
quelques mois va dépasser à autre chose
il va oublier les déboires de ces
élections
merci beaucoup taoufik jebali d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous avez hâte leur maître de
conférences en civilisation américaine